how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we get a first official look at
the Ironman mark 85 armor we've seen
this armor and leaked concept art photos
but this is our best look at it yet as
hot toys have released many photos of
the armor for those of you who are not
familiar with hot toys they do exact
replicas of characters and heroes from
movies so the images that we are seeing
here are 100% accurate I'll talk about
Iron Man's new armor and weapons in this
video but first if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe
I do monthly giveaways right now I'm
giving away 5 IMAX tickets if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so as I
just mentioned these hot toy leaks are
very accurate last year when they
released their photos and figures of the
mark 50 from infinity war it was exactly
the same as it appeared in the movie so
this is Iron Man's mark 85 armor that we
will see in Avengers end game this could
be the last Iron Man armor that we see
in the MCU for a very long time it's
pretty much all but confirmed that this
will be Robert Downey jr. 's last movie
as Iron Man and the description for the
figure reads part of the journey is the
end but what's great about this armor is
that the design is clearly taken from
and inspired by the mark 2 Iron Man
armor a classic Iron Man armor from the
comics as you can see the arc reactor
looks exactly the same as the mark 50
that we saw in Avengers infinity war
which means of course that this suit is
also nanotechnology and the armor does
look a little bit more bulky
specifically on the shoulders which
would make perfect sense
Iron Man fought a nose and infinity war
and lost the same armor and tactics
aren't going to work against him the
second time he'll need new tactics new
armor and new weapons which is where the
mark 85 comes into play the Iron Man
mark 85 armor is a tad bit bulkier yes
but take a look at this brand new weapon
the description for this weapon is a
nano lightning refocus er this will most
likely fire like Iron Man's displacer
century cannons the ones that we saw in
Avengers infinity war with the mark 50
when Iron Man used them on coal obsidian
however the name
is very interesting lightning refocus er
who has lightning
well the god of thunder probably has
some lightning
[Music]
and we saw in the very first Avengers
film Thor hit Ironman with lightning and
all it did was power up his suit
[Music]
how about that so perhaps this lightning
refocus er is a way for Thor to hit
Ironman with lightening supercharge the
Ironman suit and send out an insanely
powerful blast this would only make
sense because obviously Thor and Tony
are friends now and Tony has been
preparing for this battle since the very
first Avengers film and he most likely
knew that he would be fighting alongside
Thor again because again they called
this weapon the Nano lightning refocus
er unfortunately this was the only new
weapon that was revealed to us today but
it does say that new weapons and
accessories will be revealed soon they
most likely have not revealed them with
these figures so they could avoid all
potential spoilers for Avengers in game
perhaps one of these weapons and
accessories could even be a proton
cannon we'll have to wait till Avengers
end game comes out to find out but let
me know what you think about the new
Iron Man mark 85 armor how do you think
it looks and let me know what you think
about this new Lightning refocus or
weapon let me know all of your thoughts
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
in all things Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]